car tester michelle austyn mother says
opel touts the comfort and versatility
of its new Saphira so let's take a look
the compact MPV is well known for its
generous seating a revamp designed now
seeks to further boost its appeal
visually the new Saphira draws on the
design of its little brother the Astra
the infotainment system is also new it
includes apple carplay and android auto
compatibility as well as the Opel OnStar
service assistant since its introduction
in 1999 the Saphira has been known for
its flex 7 seating system which offers
room for up to seven passengers drivers
and passengers who travel long distances
will also appreciate the optional AGR
economic seats which make for a
comfortable and relaxing journey
Michelle says the Saphira also has
excellent handling its panoramic
windshield offers an excellent view of
the road ahead the windshield stretches
from the hood almost to the b-pillar
the version we're testing here has 147
kilowatts of power under the hood and
makes the sprint to 100 km/h and just
under nine seconds Opel Peg's fuel
consumption at 7.2 liters per 100
kilometers
the facelift is most apparent at the
front end with a sporty grille and
chiseled lines the new Saphira boasts a
more dynamic appearance and for the
first time in this category Opel is also
offering the new generation LED
headlights as an add-on but it's in the
rear where the Saphira is still a
standout minimum cargo volume is 710
liters which can be more than doubled
when the second row of seats are folded
the new interior gives a more
uncluttered impression and offers good
connectivity the Opel OnStar service
assistant turns the car into a mobile
Wi-Fi hotspot
here in the second row Michelle says
sliding back the seat is simple the seat
also shifts slightly to the center of
the vehicle for extra roominess creating
a comfortable passenger lounge the new
Saphira offers a choice of engines
including a CNG version the base model
sells for a bit over 21,000 euros in
Germany
ashell sums it up the Opel Zafira offers
good handling and the interior space is
very versatile
so the Saphira is a good family car
that's both spacious and compact enough
for day-to-day driving
in Germany the new Saphira will go on
sale in September
you